in mice 2020 Netflix debuted what might
be its most shocking and Bend were the
true crime series to date Tiger king
tells the story of the rise and fall of
Joseph Shri Vogel aka Joe exotic the
charismatic proprietor of an exotic
animal park in Oklahoma but exotic was
more than just a zookeeper and a manager
he had a knack for self-promotion
positioning himself as just as much of
an attraction as a close encounters with
lions and tigers offered by his Park
tiger King describes an increasingly
bizarre detail of a complicated personal
and professional life of Joe exotic
which culminates in an elaborate
assassination plots against Caryl Baskin
a Florida based operator of a wildcat
preserve determined to get Joe's
business and others like it shut down
it's also a story that involves other
cat aficionados the leg umeko like
arrangements exploitation shady business
practices and accidental death I am
never gonna financially recover from
this
despite 745 minute or so long episodes
filmmakers couldn't fit the entire story
into Tiger king
here are some pertinent details that
didn't make it into the series Joe
exotic is a serial monogamist if not
polygamist boasting of it's not exactly
legal simultaneous marriages to John
Finlay and Travis Maldonado after
splitting with Finlay and Maldonado's
death exotic Rica pooled with Dillon
passage but that's not the entire
history of exotics many husbands
according to intelligencer in the late
eighties exotic worked as a security
guard at the Dallas gay bar where he met
a 19-year old cowboy named Brian Ryan
they lived together for well over a
decade and were married at the bar were
they met wine was also around for many
of the events depicted in psycho king he
was there when exotics older brother
Gerald died in 1997 and when exotic
opened the GW exotic animal memorial
park in his memory Ryan died in 2001 and
according to zoo employees his passing
helped trigger exotics escalation toward
colorful and erratic behavior he also
started spending a lot of time at a gay
bar called the Copa where he met his
next husband the JC hot pants who later
ended up sentenced to life in prison for
murder after that's exotic met Finlay
and while with him at a young Insane
Clown Posse fan known only as Paul and
they all slept together in one big bed
only after Paul departed that exotic
hook up with Travis Maldonado Joe exotic
engaged in more animal related
shenanigans and cheesy stabs at
showmanship than a seven-part
documentary could show one of his
endeavors was a magic act involving
exotic animals which he performed under
the stage names
ahran Alex and Cody Ryan his assistant
Aaron stone was a guest on the podcast
show exotic Tiger King and detailed some
finer points and deeply and flattering
moments from exotics magician stint a
big trick involved making a tiger
magically appear on stage in a
previously empty cage a noisy explosion
and some pyrotechnics provided the
necessary misdirect and those things
also frighten the big cats who would
show up in the cage near the back
cringing in fear since seeing a tiger in
distress could make an audience feel
uneasy and make exotic look bad the
magician decided to get rid of the tiger
and bring in a sheep which he
spray-painted black and orange to
resemble a tiger not only that audiences
immediately recognized the painted
for what it was but it was just a
scatter the pyrotechnical effects so
there I am hiding in a secret
compartment hugging a painted sheep Joe
exotic tried to be a lot of things he
was a zoo running businessman and animal
handler and perhaps most inexplicably a
country music singer who wrote and
performed songs very much about his own
life as a tiger lover and a few of his
own personal grudges of course those
songs loaded onto CDs sold in his parks
gift shop both seemed so very personal
and yet exotic had little to do with the
enterprise apart from the marketing
according to tiger king Costa and
exotics arch-nemesis Carol Baskin those
on the tiger Kings golden pipes Baskin
said on the big cat rescue blog Joe
exotic only lips sing two songs written
and recorded by Vince Johnson and Danny
Clinton but she also added that she has
emails from Johnson and Clinton the
alleged real musicians behind those
tunes to prove it well viewers get a
large overview of most every person
involved in Tiger King they don't learn
all that much about Rick Kirkham it
shown that he's a former gonzo reporter
for the tabloid TV show Inside Edition
who went to work as a producer of Joe
exotics aliens in a talk show viewers
are left for the impression that Kirkham
largely stayed out of the personally and
legally devastating offense everyone
else in tiger King engaged in not
counting how an unknown actor heavily
implied to be exotic himself burned
Kirkham studio destroying hundreds of
hours of possibly incriminating footage
in the process charring inferno nothing
but flames and fire what's not shown in
tiger King is that Kirkham was a victim
of a second mysterious arson not long
after he left the Joe exotic compound
Kirkham moved a couple of hours away to
Dulles and settled into an apartment
which caught fire when he was still in
it
Kirkham was safely removed by
firefighters but his dog died in the
place police never made an arrest for
either fire the third episode of tiger
king dives deep into the backstory of
Caryl Baskin leader of the big cat
rescue animal preserve and subject of a
murder-for-hire plot by Oklahoma katsu
operator Joe exotic viewers learn the
Baskins previous husband Don Luis
disappeared in 1997 and Joe exotic and
his associates believe that Baskin
killed him and fed his remains to her
beloved big cats shell all world one
actually grind your husband up feed him
the tiger sir there's no evidence some
of the details of his disappearance
presented in tiger King be raised
eyebrows such as a claim that Louis
tried to file an injunction against his
wife after she threatened physical harm
but busken's side of the story
reportedly wasn't completely represented
nor was Tiger King the documentary she
initially believed she was helping to
make speaking about the filmmakers in an
interview with Vanity Fair Baskin
claimed their pictures what they were
trying to do was create the black fish
of the cat industry that's a reference
to a previous animal rights related
documentary an expose on sea world that
made waves in 2013 Baskin participated
in filming for tiger King for five years
even through the exploration of her
former husband's death which she says
awakened a lot of painful memories
she claims SAR fully participated with
authorities in trying to track down
Louis to no avail
she also shared her own theory and what
happened to him with a tiger King
filmmakers floating the notion that
Louis's secretary killed him that's an
interesting angle but one tiger King
doesn't delve into probably because it
didn't have anything to do with cat
people maybe one day another documentary
will come along to dig into the aspect
of the story a little more check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos buy your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one